ALAN SEALES: Please
welcome Eric McCormack.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Hello.
ALAN SEALES: So the show is very
different from what I typically
watch in that I guess it deals
with a lot of mental illness
and people with those
sorts of disorders.
I mean, what made you want
to tackle this kind of show?
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Well, I mean, it's
a bit of a throwback as
a show, in terms of it's
a crime solving
show at its heart,
but the guy doing the solving
is the interesting character.
I mean, that there's
a long period of time,
I think, with cop shows,
in the last 10, 15
years, where Dick Wolf
with "Law and Order" said,
we don't care about
their personalities,
we don't go home with the
cops, it's all about the crime.
And "CSI" took
that even further.
But this is a throwback
to "Columbo" and "Quincy"
and stuff, where the central
character has quirks,
he has downfalls.
And in this case, he has
paranoid schizophrenia.
And also, he's not
a cop, nor is he
a lawyer-- he is a professor.
Most episodes begin
in the classroom
with him teaching
university students.
And in this one, in
fact, in a couple
of-- perhaps even
in the next scene,
we are actually in
the Sorbonne in Paris,
and he's lecturing there.
I was drawn to it
because as a character,
he is so multi-faceted.
Like Dr. House, he can
be a bit of an asshole.
He's the smartest
guy in the room,
but he can also, because
of his condition,
suddenly be terrified.
He can be hallucinating
something that ultimately will
help him, but in the moment,
it can absolutely destroy him.
ALAN SEALES: So your
character is who?
ERIC MCCORMACK: He
is Dr. Daniel Pierce.
He is a neuroscience professor.
ALAN SEALES: Eccentric--
eccentric neuropsychiatrist.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, if paranoid
schizophrenia
is an eccentricity, I
guess he's eccentric.
He's a brilliant, brilliant
guy that basically
had his first break with
reality at about the age of 21
and could very easily
have gone off the rails,
as so often happens,
but he stayed
at the university he was
at and eventually started
teaching there.
LeVar Burton plays
his old friend
who is the dean of
the university and is,
at least, when we started the
series, two years ago, was
keeping Daniel's condition
kind of under wraps.
It was pretty much a secret.
Everyone thought of
him as eccentric,
not realizing that he was
a diagnosed schizophrenic.
And that's come
out in the series,
since the beginning
of the second season.
He was kind of outed
on the witness stand.
But still it's amazing because
when I first read this,
I thought, I wonder
how many people
living with this
condition hold down
such a position of
power and influence.
ALAN SEALES: Without
people knowing?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Right.
Without people knowing, or
even with people knowing.
What we all know about
paranoid schizophrenia,
if we know anything at all, is
the guy outside the 7-Eleven
is crazy and he's
talking to himself,
and that's what the
average person sees,
or they see the 6 o'clock news,
and someone's just shut up
a room full of people,
and guess what?
He's probably schizophrenic.
So that is the stigma
that gets out there,
when in fact, there's a
tremendous number of people
living with it that,
in fact, run companies.
And my model-- after
I got the part,
I did a lot of research and
there's an incredible woman
named Elyn Saks who wrote a
book called "The Center Cannot
Hold."
She's a university professor.
She's a law professor at USC.
But she was full blown
schizophrenic in the early 70s,
and without her meds,
would still be so now.
And yet, she teaches students,
she writes books, she lectures.
She's a brilliant lecturer.
And I thought, it doesn't
hurt to show America
there's another side
of mental illness.
ALAN SEALES: So
is that more what
appealed to you about the role?
You just wanted to increase
education of the subject?
ERIC MCCORMACK: That's
kind of a byproduct.
And it's a great one.
Ultimately, you just want
to play an interesting part
that the audience is drawn to.
I didn't think, when I
finished the sitcom, hey,
I should solve
crimes, that's what
I should do, how can I do that?
But it is the most popular
form of television, cable
or network, and defined an
interesting way into that.
He's drawn into the FBI.
They use him, but he
is not an FBI agent.
He's a professor whose
expertise is called upon.
So I like the academic setting.
Like I say, every episode
has university scenes.
And you don't see a lot
of that on any series.
We have high school shows,
but we don't necessarily
have a lot of college
shows and particularly
at that level of academia.
So that drew me, too.
ALAN SEALES: The TA in the
show-- he's been in nine years,
I think, in the
college [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
You're right.
ALAN SEALES: Nine years and six
degrees and still won't leave.
First of all, I love this story.
I was cast early.
Ken Biller, who created
the show-- we got together.
And then I helped him cast
the rest of the parts.
And my TA was to be
named Max Lewicki.
And we took three
guys to network,
two of them who
looked like Lewickis.
And then this good
looking black guy,
and of course, he walked
in, and he was great.
We said, so he's got the part--
we're going to change the name,
right?
And Ken said, no,
no, let's leave it.
Max Lewicki.
ALAN SEALES: That
will throw them off.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly.
So of course, we
waited a long time,
and we were deep in
the second season
before we finally explained that
he was adopted by the Lewickis
or whatever.
And I'm always yelling at him.
He's quite beleaguered.
But it's fun to shout, Lewicki,
and have that guy walk out.
ALAN SEALES: Was it Arjay Smith?
Right?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Arjay Smith.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: He's just
a little [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN SEALES: From Nickelodeon's
"Journey of Allen Strange"?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: For
some people here.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Apparently the
young people liked the show.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
He was actually
like a kid actor--
ALAN SEALES: Really?
ERIC MCCORMACK: That has
grown into this lovely guy.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah.
I love him on the show.
He's always right there--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: You know,
giving you the one-two punch.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly right.
ALAN SEALES: But is that weird?
Like, what in the
show made you decide
to make him kind of like,
sort of, a nurse to you?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well, actually--
ALAN SEALES: Because he
lives with you, on the show.
ERIC MCCORMACK: It was
revealed in the second season,
but we explore it
more this season
that that's literally
what he was.
We met because the
character, five years ago,
had a complete-- he
went out of his mind
and was hospitalized for six
months and institutionalized.
ALAN SEALES: Spoiler.
Spoiler.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well, yeah.
We've always hinted at that.
We've just never
exported it dramatically.
And this season, we get
some great flashbacks where
we get to see him
meet Lewicki and while
ALAN SEALES: In season three?
ERIC MCCORMACK: He gets
that job in season three.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: So that's great
for Arjay to get to do that.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, that's cool.
That's really neat.
So the show, going
into season three now,
is-- I mean, it's popular.
It's been renewed.
TNT's liking it.
What do you think really
is driving the fan base?
What do you think
people are finding
so interesting about the show?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well,
I've seen with this today
that when I started,
20 years ago,
and trying to get on
television, you still
needed a pretty big audience--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: To be a success.
And of course, as you all know,
it's changed entirely now.
And you can be a successful
show with a very small group
of people if that
group of people
are rabid and
constantly googling you.
If they do have a
rabid, devoted fanbase,
and the particular
network you're on
doesn't demand a whole
lot of people-- I mean,
"Mad Men" had a
million people a year
for the first four
or five years, right?
So I think--
ALAN SEALES: Which is not a lot.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah,
which is not a lot.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
This particular show
we have-- I think we
averaged about 5 million
the last two seasons.
And they're people that when
I first signed on with TNT,
I said, who's your audience?
And Michael Wright,
who runs the thing,
said, it's 50-year-old women.
And I said, all right.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: There you go.
They loved me.
50-year-olds loved me.
I mean, I'm the gay best
friend they never had.
So that was kind of our way
in, which which was that.
But also, TNT has a
lot of crime shows.
So there's people that
love to solve crimes.
So you mix those
two things together.
And we definitely
have our fanbase,
but we're trying to
expand it because I
love that beyond the
mystery of the week
is this very complex character.
And we can do that in this clip.
I don't know if you've
ever seen the show,
but him hallucinating is a
very big part of the show.
He is basically off his meds,
not for any good reason.
It's the hubris of--
and this is, again,
part of the condition.
People that get on
their meds sometimes
cycle off because
they don't like
how they feel when
they're on them.
They don't like
being controlled.
He's definitely
someone that doesn't
like having his mind controlled.
He's a brain guy.
So he freely
hallucinates sometimes.
And in the most of the
episodes, those hallucinations
are part of what's guiding
him towards-- they're
the reason he
hallucinates that woman
or we have one this season
where I hallucinate the devil.
I actually have great
conversations with the devil.
But there's a reason for
it that is leading me
to solving the case.
ALAN SEALES: Well
how much research
did you do for the role?
I mean, did you just say,
oh, this person's imaginary,
so I'll pretend, or
what all did you do?
ERIC MCCORMACK: No.
I didn't write the show.
Ken and Mike Sussman wrote it.
So a lot of that
was on the page.
My research had to do with
what do symptoms look like,
and what do they
feel like, and how?
You know, sometimes with
series, you can sort of get it
right in the pilot,
and then eventually,
by the second
season, maybe you've
figured out the character.
I couldn't afford to.
I thought the mental
health community would just
shut me down if I
came out half-cocked.
So I did a lot of research
up front with Elyn's book
and Oliver Sacks'
books and just trying
to get a sense of--
because I not only had
to get his mental
health condition
right-- I had to get him right
as a teacher, as an academic,
as a neuroscientist.
And there's a lot of-- I mean,
that's some of the most fun
stuff to say is ventromedial
prefrontal cortex.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: It's fun to say.
So that kind of research
was crucial up front, too.
ALAN SEALES: Well, you
meet any of the patients
with similar
symptoms or anything?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well,
Ellen was a big one.
I sat down to lunch with her.
And I did ask.
I mean, it was very
laid out in her book.
But to hear her talk about it,
herself, and-- hers was more,
as with a lot of people
with the condition,
is more voices
than it is visual.
But this is television,
so his voices
tend to have-- it's gonna
be actors we can cast,
and you can see them.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: But so yeah,
I did a lot of research
in that department, to make sure
that we weren't doing anything
hokey.
Of course, it's
television-- there's
going to be an element of,
are you going to buy this?
But there's nothing we've done--
there's no-- a lot of cases
that we look into, the reason
my character's brought on
is because there's
a mental illness,
you know, so someone
looks like they're crazy.
Well, actually,
they're not crazy.
They have this
condition, which made
it look like they were
confessing to something
that they didn't do.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
it's always you--
it seems like it's you
convincing or changing
the mind of somebody
who was convinced of--
based on a preconceived
notion, I guess.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Right.
Right.
ALAN SEALES: Right
ERIC MCCORMACK: And
so it's not just
that through the character,
we get to see layers of him.
We get to see, through
his expertise, all
of these other conditions.
And it's becoming, as we know,
a huge part of the legal system
now, that, you know, it's
not black and white anymore.
You plead insanity or
not plead insanity.
There are so many
conditions that
are now recognized
medically that
are going to have--
they're going to come out
in the courtroom as a defense.
And they're going to be
harder and harder to bat away.
We're going to have to
face the fact that we
have to deal with
mental illness.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: We
can't just lock it up.
ALAN SEALES: So you won an
award-- the Award of Courage--
for what they say, your
groundbreaking portrayal of Dr.
Daniel Pierce, right?
So what is that award?
I mean, why do
they give that out?
ERIC MCCORMACK: It was the
neuroscience department at UCLA
that gives various
awards every year.
But there's one for media
and accurate representations
of their work in the media.
And this was more for the
portrayal of mental illness,
more than it was
the neuroscience,
but because they
like it, I thought,
it kind of covers both.
But the beautiful thing was
it was presented by Elyn Saks.
So the fact that
she got up and said
to the world, what he's doing
is accurate and true to what
people living with it go
through, it meant a lot.
ALAN SEALES: Hm.
So how do you play
this character?
I mean, I guess,
how do you prepare
for this character
differently from other things
that you've done?
ERIC MCCORMACK: There's
a frantic state of mind
that is not hard for me
to be in, unfortunately.
He just, he very
rarely is at peace.
And so mostly,
it's about energy.
It's about coming
in with a lot of it
and understanding
that that's what
he's always trying to tamp down.
It's not just the voices, but
the paranoia and the fear.
The fear is very real.
And the one-- I thought this
piece of writing was great,
particularly, once I met
Ellen, was in the classroom,
he's a rock star.
In the classroom,
he's got his students.
They love him.
It takes me back.
I don't know if--
ALAN SEALES: Throwing
themselves at him?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
I'm probably the oldest
person in the room,
but there was a show called "The
Paper Chase" in the late '70s
that John Houseman played
this legal professor.
And I remember the
classroom scenes.
He was very, very vat.
He was very-- but you
were riveted to him
because you watched
students riveted to him.
And it's kind of the
same thing here, too.
He's fun and he's funny.
And he loves the jargon.
He loves teaching.
He gets outside the classroom,
and in a group of people
he can be a complete
basket case.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Right.
So you also direct and
produce this, correct?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I
am a producer on it.
And I just directed an episode
this year, which was great.
ALAN SEALES: The second episode
of season three, I think?
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Second is the one
that follows this Paris episode.
Yeah.
We're in Paris because at
the end of last season,
I quit my job, as you can see,
and followed this woman that I
love, and--
ALAN SEALES: Who is real--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Who is real.
ALAN SEALES: Which confused me--
ERIC MCCORMACK: The blond girl.
Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Confused
me for awhile.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well, she's
the girl-- the blond girl--
that was in the apartment
with me, saying,
you know, you've
got to be careful,
you're not on your
meds-- she's not real.
I've hallucinated
her for 25 years.
She is a girl that
I, as we learned
at the end of the first season--
because the whole first season,
the audience knew
she wasn't real,
but it's like why is she--
am I hallucinating someone
from my past, am I
hallucinating an ex-lover?
It turns out that she was a
girl I saw across a crowded room
and never met.
But from that day-- that was
pretty much the day I had
my first break with reality
and I started, in my mind,
dating her and calling her and--
ALAN SEALES: You were
in love with the idea.
ERIC MCCORMACK: I was
in love with this woman
who became very, very real.
And at the end of
the first season--
it was a really cool
episode-- we met.
Kelly Rowan played
both parts-- the woman
I had been hallucinating
for 25 years,
and the real woman, who I
never saw since that party,
is my doctor, after I
lose my shit, one day.
I'm taken to the hospital,
and there's Natalie.
And I'm like, they're
giving me medication--
why am I still seeing you?
And she's like, we've
never met, Dr. Pierce,
my name is Caroline.
And it was great just to
realize that sometimes,
like I say, when you
see someone talking
to themselves in the street,
they're talking to someone very
real-- maybe their own
father, maybe somebody
that is, as far as they're
concerned, very, very there.
And I think that also helps
to remind an audience that--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: For what
they're going through,
it's absolutely here now.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
let's get back
to the producing part of it.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Oh,
the producing part.
ALAN SEALES: That was
the original question.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
So when I came out with
Ken, I just said, look,
you don't need my help
producing the show,
but I think I need to be a
guardian of this character
in a way that-- because
he's writing the show.
Ken is up there
with [INAUDIBLE].
So as we're working with
different directors,
it's crucial that
somebody on set
be guarding the heart
of the show, and--
ALAN SEALES: So what does
a producer do, exactly?
ERIC MCCORMACK: A producer
can do any number of things.
I mean, you can give money--
you can give a million bucks
and never do anything else.
ALAN SEALES: Is that
the executive producer?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah,
well, exactly right.
I just did a movie before
Christmas-- an independent film
with Parker Posey.
And one of the producers
is Lars Ulrich,
the drummer from Metallica.
He showed up one day to say, hi.
I think he just gave some money.
You know?
I mean, that's-- but
he's still a producer.
You can be the person
that owns the property.
You can buy a book
and say, I'm going
to make this into a movie.
You never have to do anything
else except own that book,
and you're still a producer,
whereas, the guys that
make our show happen day
after day after day after day
are a different
kind of producer.
I mean, they are hands on,
making the show happen.
Ken, who created the show,
is the executive producer
because the words
come out of his head.
And in my case, like
I said, I produce it
by helping to cast it and
by, when the show is shot,
helping to edit it and have
a say in how it comes out.
ALAN SEALES: Hm.
That's really neat.
OK.
So the show is set in Chicago.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: You film in LA.
ALAN SEALES: Are there
any challenges with that?
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Well, there's a few.
There are no palm
trees in Chicago.
So there's just
certain places we just
can't point the camera anywhere.
We're like, oh, Christ,
what are we going to do now?
But there's that.
Plus, I decided-- we shot
the pilot in Toronto, which
is where I'm from,
which was great.
All of those university shots
are the University of Toronto.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, really?
OK.
ERIC MCCORMACK: And so we
had to recreate that in LA.
There's no buildings
in Los Angeles that
look like that except for
one church in Pasadena.
So that's where we shoot, now,
all of our university stuff.
ALAN SEALES: In the
internal-- the internal shots?
ERIC MCCORMACK: No.
The internal's all a set.
But these external,
when I'm outside
on benches and
beautiful trees, that's
all this little church
courtyard, which is--
ALAN SEALES: Oh, cool.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Hysterical.
That, and I also decided that,
based on my research, someone
with his condition--
particularly,
someone not on their
meds-- they need routine.
They need the comfort
of things not changing,
which is why-- I don't know
if you saw in that scene--
what I'm listening to on my
headphones, it's a Walkman.
It's a Sony Walkman that
he's had for 25 years.
The sneakers, he's
probably never changed.
And that coat and scarf were
in the pilot, and I said,
I think he always wears this.
This is his armor
against the world.
And in Los Angeles, in June,
sometimes I hate myself.
ALAN SEALES: So-- well, you're
saying that the character,
I guess, the people with
schizophrenia like to have
stability and things
not changing--
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Yeah, they need it.
ALAN SEALES: Is there a link
to OCD, as well, with that,
or is this
holistically different?
ERIC MCCORMACK: With OCD, it's--
and I'm not going to become
a scientist here because I just
play one on TV-- but I mean,
yeah, I'm sure there's
definitely a link.
And in this case, though,
it's more about just not
letting fear rule you
and having control.
Paranoid schizophrenics
generally feel out of control.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: They cannot
control what's around them.
ALAN SEALES: Because
they legitimately
don't know what's
real and what's not?
Or--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well, I mean,
it does vary in degrees,
like, for instance, most
paranoid schizophrenics--
and I shouldn't use that
term-- people living
with paranoid schizophrenia
don't necessarily
hallucinate visually.
More common is voices-- sounds,
even-- that kind of thing.
So it does vary.
But what was the
previous thing you said?
Something about--
ALAN SEALES: The challenges
of filming in LA?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Oh, no, no.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, no, no.
The OCD.
ERIC MCCORMACK: The OCD--
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Whereas, you know,
I think OCD is also a need.
It's a need for
control, too-- a need
to control your environment
as best you can.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So the creator of
the show-- what
was his idea behind even
bringing it into conception?
I mean, does he have
somebody that he
knows that's living
with similar symptoms?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I think there
was someone close in his life
that-- I'd probably have to
let him answer that question.
But Mike Sussman,
the other co-creator,
had actually come
to Ken and said,
I don't know what
to do with this,
but I think at the
center of a show,
someone with paranoid
schizophrenia
could be really interesting.
And Ken was already
working with TNT
on trying to come up with
another mystery solving show.
And then he came
up with the idea
of setting it in-- making
him a neuroscientist.
I mean, that's the
part that I love,
is that someone who knows more
about the brain than anybody
in the room, his own
brain is his worst enemy.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
I always feel like
there's a little bit
of ice outside of the classroom.
The character is always
slightly just holding back,
being incredibly
mean to somebody
because they feel
they're intellectually--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Your
character feels
that the person is
intellectually inferior?
So you're like, why
are you bothering me,
why don't you get this?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I
mean, it's nice.
I was quite likable
on "Will and Grace,"
and it's fun to
sometimes not be likable.
I mean, Dr. Pierce is a dick
sometimes, which is really fun.
And it is hubris.
It is intellectual hubris.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: You know?
And to see someone
behave that way
and lord his intelligence
over the room,
and then suddenly be terrified
because he saw someone there
who was not there is to remind
everyone of his humility,
as well.
ALAN SEALES: Well, OK.
So "Will and Grace" was the
first time on prime time TV
that two openly gay characters
were leads in a sitcom.
So that was
groundbreaking, brought
all of this educational--
ERIC MCCORMACK: If you don't
include "The Odd Couple."
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Yes.
Well, were they?
Yes, they specifically said.
So that brought a
lot of awareness
and a lot of, I guess,
education to the gay community,
or focus on it,
which made people
more comfortable and whatnot.
So do you think that playing
Dr. David Pierce on "Perception"
is going to do the same
thing for mental illness
or bring that to light?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I mean, it would
be great if that was the case.
I mean, certainly with "Will
and Grace," we never-- I mean,
it was a sitcom, and it was
an outrageous one, at times.
So we didn't pat ourselves
on the back ever,
with hey, look what we're doing.
Time took that and last
year, the Vice President
said, on "Meet the Press,"
that-- out of the blue,
because they were talking
about gay marriage,
and he said he thought that
"Will and Grace" had done more
to educate the American
public on them.
And that took time.
The show, we started in '98.
So hopefully, with
a show like this,
there will be other shows, and
mental illness-- we'd have to.
I mean, the last few weeks of
school shootings and everything
else, I mean, every time,
as soon as it happens,
it's not the gun's fault--
it's mental illness.
It's like, OK, guys, well,
if that's the case, then
what are we going to do?
How are we going to
increase the funding
and increase the awareness and
help these people before they
get lost in the system?
You know?
So this show is not going
to cure that overnight.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
But hopefully it's
putting that idea
into people's minds,
that not everyone with
the condition is dangerous
and that the more
educators that we have
and the more education
that we have, the better.
ALAN SEALES: You know, it seems
to me that it's easy-- I mean,
just like anything
else in the world--
I'm going to get on my political
high horse for a second--
that it's very easy to just
ignore things and pretend
they're OK, and let somebody
else deal with your problems.
And then as soon as there's like
a school shooting or something
statistically relevant that
says we need to pay attention,
those people are
like, I don't know
what they're talking about.
Right?
So your character in
"Perception"-- I think it
speaks to that a lot.
And you know, it might not, by
itself, make a big difference,
but it could-- it's like
the very tip of the iceberg.
ERIC MCCORMACK: What I
do like is that every,
I would say out of-- say we're
doing 15 episodes this year.
Probably out of
10 of those, there
is someone who is either
wrongly accused because
of a mental illness
or the mental illness
is not something
easily diagnosed.
It's something that
takes his expertise,
over the course of the
episode, to go, it's this.
So in the end of an
episode, an audience
has learned that much
more about a condition
they would never otherwise
have heard about--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Much as
people do with physical things
on "ER" or "Grey's Anatomy."
You walk away going, oh,
I've never heard of that.
But with this, it's like,
well, guess what-- there really
is something called Aphasia,
where people can't recognize
a face, or whatever it is.
Interesting.
And it also helps people to feel
less alone because everybody's
got something.
I mean, like--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: A
quarter of the country's
technically depressed.
You know?
I mean, it's like
everyone's got something
that actually qualifies as--
ALAN SEALES: Or falls on the
Asperger's syndrome somewhere.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Mental illness.
Yeah.
Yeah, or in the spectrum.
Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: It's
becoming more and more
a part of the conversation in
ways it never was 25 years ago.
ALAN SEALES: So everything on
the show-- is it actually real?
All of these diagnoses
and everything?
So do you have a
consultant that's
with you in the writer's
room or on set with you?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes, we do
have David Eagleman, who
wrote an incredible
book called "Incognito--
The Secret Lives of the
Brain," or "The Secret Life
of the Brain."
He is kind of what
Pierce would be, I guess,
if Pierce didn't have this
condition because Eagleman's
in his '40s, and
he's kind of hip
neuroscience
professor and author.
And his books are about the
aspects of the brain that we
don't think of, just
cool stuff like--
I remember the first
time, when I read it,
the first fact that
jumped out at me,
that the brain cannot
process what's coming at you,
for instance, as fast as a
fast ball comes at a pitcher.
So the idea--
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: That a
pitcher chooses to swing,
or chooses not to
swing, at a fast ball--
ALAN SEALES: The batter.
ERIC MCCORMACK: --at the
batter, is a fallacy.
There wouldn't be
enough time to choose.
It's instinct.
It's physical
instinct that makes
him go because the
brain is slower than--
ALAN SEALES: That's
why they get hit
in the head when
it's a stray pitch.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
That kind of thing.
ALAN SEALES: Because they don't
have enough time to react.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Basically that.
So to have a guy
like that, we know
the writers do their research.
They come up with stuff.
They write it.
They write the lingo, the
lectures, the diagnoses.
And then he will go
through every script
and say, nah, that's
not how he'd say it.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
how does that work?
Did you go through and
you're like, all right,
let's do this disorder.
All right, let's write about it.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Kind of.
I mean, once you
realize, hey, they
picked us up for another season,
we need 15 disorders to film,
you know, they start
trying to find some.
And we just did one where
our most junior writer
was like, you finally
got a script, go.
And she found something called
mirror-touch synesthesia which
is rare but exists
as a condition
where if you're feeling angry,
it's like the ultimate empath,
like what's her name
from "Star Trek."
It's total empathy.
So I would feel your anger.
And if you were feeling
nauseous, I might throw up.
And we did a whole episode
not on that condition,
but her condition leads us--
she's witness to a crime.
Someone is stabbed in the
neck, and she goes down
because she feels the
pain of the knife.
ALAN SEALES: Oh,
that's so weird.
I mean, I want to [INAUDIBLE]
on this for a second.
But does she sense it?
Does the person-- what is it?
ERIC MCCORMACK: She feels it.
ALAN SEALES: Like,
the person senses--
ERIC MCCORMACK: She feels it.
ALAN SEALES: So if you
just come in to me,
and you're acting all
happy and everything, like,
your pheromones--
you're letting off
that you're the angriest
person right now.
But you're happy right
now, and I would just
get really angry because of it?
ERIC MCCORMACK: You
would take it on.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
ERIC MCCORMACK: You
would take it on.
ALAN SEALES: There's so much
of the brain that baffles me,
like by paying attention
to the five senses
that we're just not
paying attention to
and we're not listening to.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: That's really cool.
I just totally got myself
sidetracked on that.
Sorry.
Let's see.
Yeah, OK.
I talked about that.
All right, so speaking of "Star
Trek," LeVar Burton, right?
ERIC MCCORMACK: LeVar Burton.
ALAN SEALES: OK.
Every time I look at him--
this is another side note,
but I always think it's
weird that he doesn't have
the visor on, every time
I see him without it.
And I grew up watching
"Reading Rainbow," right?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Did you hear
about the whole "Reading
Rainbow" thing
that just happened?
ALAN SEALES: I invested in it.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Oh, you did?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
The kickstarter, yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
That's quite amazing.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
I thought it was great.
ERIC MCCORMACK: His
last day of shooting
for this season
was that first day.
ALAN SEALES: Oh,
really? [INAUDIBLE]
ERIC MCCORMACK: He
told me the day before.
We're hoping to raise
$1 million in 30 days.
And by 6 o'clock on the first
day, while we were shooting,
they had $1 million.
It was amazing.
I don't know what they have
now-- five or six, or something
crazy.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I invested
in it a couple of days ago.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
So he owns the visor.
ALAN SEALES: Does he really?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
Well I love LeVar.
LeVar directed two
episodes this year.
ALAN SEALES: Have
you worn the visor?
ERIC MCCORMACK: We have so
much-- that, I have not--
ALAN SEALES: Have you worn it?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I think
he might let me if I ask.
But-- but-- no one owns
his career like LeVar does.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
The other day, he
tweeted-- because I know
him from "Roots" in like '77
when he played Kunta Kinte.
And he literally tweeted
the other day, hey Denver,
Kunta's in town.
Like, I can't even imagine
saying, hey, boys, Will's here.
But I think he's
got a tattoo that
says-- if you read it
this way, it says "LeVar,"
but if you look at it
this way, it says "Kunta."
Amazing.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
I'm cool with that.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
He's an awesome guy.
ALAN SEALES: So what made you
reach out to him for the role?
Like, why does he make sense?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Ken Biller,
who created the show,
ran "Star Trek"
for several years.
ALAN SEALES: Well, there you go.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah, he was
the show runner on that show
for like four years, I think.
So he was already pretty
adept at coming up
with some crazy shit, you know?
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: When you're
in season six of "Star Trek,"
and you're just making up
planets and races and language,
it's a pretty good
background for--
ALAN SEALES: That's pretty cool.
So for season four
of "Perception,"
you have to, like, have some
character that thinks he's--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
Exactly right.
ALAN SEALES: Knock
on wood-- who thinks
he's in a "Star Trek" episode.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: That's my
writer's contribution--
ERIC MCCORMACK:
That's a good one.
ALAN SEALES: For you.
ERIC MCCORMACK: That's good.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Wait,
actually, I've got to say,
we pretty much had that.
And I'll tell you why.
Beginning of last season, we set
an entire episode at Comic Con.
So there was a crime
involved there.
And I had to go.
And I had to be at
Comic Con, surrounded
by Darth Vaders
and Princess Leias.
And I hallucinate one of
the-- like a Comic Con
fan in some sort of space gear.
And he was supposed to be
dressed as either something
"Star Trek" or-- no,
we had "Star Wars."
He was supposed to be dressed
as someone "Star Trek,"
and then we couldn't
get the rights
at the last minute or something.
But I was supposed to he
hallucinating Leonard Nimoy.
And we almost had
him playing himself.
And then he backed out
at the last minute.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, no.
ERIC MCCORMACK: So instead
I hallucinated this man.
ALAN SEALES: This person
cosplaying Leonard Nimoy?
ERIC MCCORMACK: What
I want to pitch,
next season-- I want
to hallucinate someone
that thinks I'm a hallucination.
So just whenever I
see him, I walk up,
and he's like, leave me
alone, leave me alone!
And he's running from me.
And I'm like, wait!
ALAN SEALES: No, I'm real!
I'm real!
ERIC MCCORMACK: I'm real!
I think that would be--
ALAN SEALES: What
if your character
is hallucinating a guy
who thinks you're fake.
ERIC MCCORMACK: That's
what I'm saying.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
I'm hallucinating a guy--
ALAN SEALES: So every time you
walk up to your hallucination--
ERIC MCCORMACK: That
believes he's the real thing.
ALAN SEALES: I would watch that.
ERIC MCCORMACK: You see?
ALAN SEALES: In fact,
I am watching it.
So the rest of the cast--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Is actually
very, very good.
So you've got, who?
Rachael Leigh Cook.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Rachael Leigh
Cook who was in "She's All
That" that I don't know
if anybody [INAUDIBLE]--
I guess I was
probably in my 30s,
by the time that movie was made.
So I didn't-- it wasn't
a big one for me.
But there are some, like,
younger women on our set that
work in different departments
for whom "She's All That"
was like this touchstone
movie of coming of age.
So they love-- and
Rachel's awesome.
ALAN SEALES: So the role has
obviously, probably got-- what?
The most screen time, second
to your character, right?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Mhm.
ALAN SEALES: So it was obviously
an important role to cast.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Like, why her?
ERIC MCCORMACK:
She's the FBI agent.
She's the one who has
these cases that there
is an element they
can't solve, and if it
seems to have a scientific
or a neuroscientific element,
she'll come to me,
which happens--
ALAN SEALES: Every episode.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Every week.
ALAN SEALES: It seems
like the only people she--
ERIC MCCORMACK:
It's exactly right.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: And we
were seeing a lot of,
like, tall,
beautiful, tough, you
know, sort of almost
typical kind of women
they'd see on these
kind of shows.
ALAN SEALES: Like
Jennifer Garner.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
And, like, really capable.
And then in came Rachel, who's
quite petite and gorgeous.
But you don't immediately
go, FBI agent.
But it made me think of
"The Silence of the Lambs,"
when Judy-- Jodie-- Judy F--
ALAN SEALES: Jodie Foster.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Jodie Foster.
Judy?
When Jodie Foster
was standing there--
I think was up there at the
morgue or the funeral home--
and there's like five or six
state troopers standing around
her.
And they're all, like, big guys.
And she's this big.
And they're all staring at her
like, what are-- who are you?
What are you going to do?
And I remember just
thinking how it illustrated
how much of a mountain
she had to climb.
And that's kind
of what we wanted.
We wanted someone who was
constantly trying to prove
herself in a man's world and
in this very sort of misogynist
FBI, and that bringing me in
helped-- that I wasn't, I mean,
my characters hardly
macho, so it's--
She came in with a kind
of a sense of humor.
She's has a very
ironic delivery.
She's a very funny, funny girl.
And her audition just
was-- it just sort of
set the room on
fire, originally.
ALAN SEALES: So in your head,
when you saw the character
on paper first, did you have a
different idea of what it would
be before she started putting
it out there in the real--
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Well, the other thing
was that she's supposed to
have been a student of mine.
And there's a little
bit of that-- what
I call the don't stand so close
to me relationship which-- God,
my references are ancient today.
What the fuck.
I don't what that is.
Let me tell you an
Al Jolson story.
But so we needed somebody
of a certain age.
She needed to be kind
of her early 30s,
for me to have taught her.
And she appeared to still be
quite young which was great,
too.
So that sort of romantic,
unrealized thing
has been a thread
throughout the show, too.
So we need to find
someone not only who
would be an unlikely
but fascinating FBI
agent-- we needed someone
that you kind of root for.
I learned early on-- you
know this term "shipping"?
So you know.
You're on the internet.
But I didn't know it.
So for those that
don't know, it's
mostly young women that
watch shows like "Bones"
or "The Mentalist" and root
for these lead characters
to get together.
And they root for
the relationship.
So they start
shipping these shows
and tweeting them
all of the time
and creating blogs about them
and fan fiction and everything.
So I thought, I want this
to happen right away.
I am not wasting any time here.
So as the show started-- the
show premiered two years ago,
and I was actually here in New
York doing a show on Broadway.
And I got Twitter at that
point, for the first time.
And I just started tweeting
constantly, start shipping us,
everybody, don't you want
to us to sleep together?
I know you haven't
seen the show yet,
but you're going to really
want us to sleep together
eventually, so tweet.
And so it kind of started.
And now that she's in the shower
with Donnie, with Scott Wolf
there, as we saw,
there's a lot of--
ALAN SEALES: "Party of Five."
ERIC MCCORMACK: "Party of Five."
He's another awesome guy.
There's a lot of shippers
going, why is she with Donnie?
I don't like her with him.
ALAN SEALES: Hold it.
What is it from "Twilight"?
The club-- whatever in
the club underground.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly right.
ALAN SEALES: Club Long
Hair and Club Shirtless,
or-- I don't know who they are.
I don't watch the show.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So if you guys
have any questions for Eric,
please use the mics over here.
Because we've got
a few minutes left,
I want to hit on the Broadway
that you just mentioned.
So your past life, you've
been a Broadway star.
ERIC MCCORMACK:
Well, the theater
was definitely my start.
I didn't even audition
for television
until I was almost 30.
It was my 20s were spent
in Canada at the Stratford
festival, doing Shakespeare,
and regional theaters
across that country.
And I did "The Music
Man" here, years ago.
And then this last one I
did was just incredible.
It was a revival of Gore Vidal's
"The Best Man" with James Earl
Jones and Angela Lansbury and
John Larroquette and Candice
Bergen and Michael McKean-- this
incredibly big and wonderful
cast.
And I got to play a real
asshole which was just awesome.
It's a political piece.
It's two guys running
for the same party,
though one seems
very, very liberal--
it was the John
Larroquette character--
and I got to be kind of the
Republican asshole, which
was so great.
ALAN SEALES: Do you
like playing the asshole
versus the nice guy?
ERIC MCCORMACK:
I've actually been
a villain in a lot of things.
My first big television role was
on a western-- "Lonesome Dove,"
the spin-off from
the miniseries.
And I got to play the
sort of badass Civil War
Confederate colonel.
ALAN SEALES: That's fun.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Well, thanks for coming.
I used to watch "Will and
Grace" all of the time.
And I remember one
episode that you guys had,
where you filmed it live.
And you guys were hysterical
laughing the whole time, which
was very funny because--
ERIC MCCORMACK: I was not.
Messing was dying
to be Carol Burnett.
So she was determined
to fall apart.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But I
assume that, always,
filming "Will and
Grace" must been
the funniest thing every day.
So I was just curious how
your experience filming
a more serious show
was, compared to some--
ERIC MCCORMACK: It's definitely
two different muscles.
I started in drama.
I mean, I started in--
that was my-- comedy was
this other thing that I
thought, that must be fun.
And when I finally
got to LA and started
auditioning for sitcoms, it
was an entirely other world.
We had a tremendous
amount of fun,
particularly because
everything was
shot in front of
a live audience.
We shot an episode in four hours
in front of a studio audience
who by second and
third season had
had their tickets for
six months, you know?
And so they were
excited to be there.
And I realized
very early on that
if you fuck up in the
first scene, they love it.
So I just, I'd start
throwing F bombs around,
and they were like, oh
my God, [INAUDIBLE]--?
So it was fantastic.
So that's why, if you google
"Will and Grace" outtakes,
sometimes they're funnier
than some of the episodes
because we had a lot of fun.
And we still have a
lot of fun on this show
but it is an
entirely different--
it takes 14 hours to
shoot it in a day,
and it's not as funny a subject.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: So how did
you get your start, though?
So you started out doing
theater in high school?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
I did a play in first grade.
It kept going from there.
It was always theatre.
I didn't do, like,
commercials or anything.
I went to high school
with Mike Myers
on the south side of Toronto.
ALAN SEALES: He's Canadian.
Yeah.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah so we
knew each other a little bit.
But he was already in
Canadian television
when he was like nine, ten.
And then he was doing
commercials and episodes
of things.
But I was strictly just theatre
at school and competitions--
you know, skit
competitions and stuff.
But 11th grade is
when it sort of-- I
did a production of "Godspell,"
and that was, you know.
ALAN SEALES: Who were
you in "Godspell"?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Christ.
As I affectionately
call him, Christ.
That changed everything because
it's kind of a rock musical,
compared to-- we had been
doing "Annie Get Your Gun"
and all of those
old-fashioned things.
And all of a sudden, to
have my peers, who had never
really accepted me-- I was
not an athlete or anything--
suddenly, like, forced
to watch one of the songs
at an assembly, you know,
and at the end of it,
they jumped on their
feet and cheered.
It was like, OK, I can do this.
This I can do for a living.
ALAN SEALES: So you sing.
ERIC MCCORMACK: I sing.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, of
course, because you
were in "Music Man" and
everything, as well.
Yes.
So you just did a
concert-- what was this?
A year or two ago?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I
did a show that I
had been sort of creating
in my brain for 30 years.
It was called "The Concert I
Never Gave-- except for, like,
2000 times in my
bedroom" because I did.
I was that guy, at 16.
When other people
were doing things
like dating and drinking,
I was in my bedroom
dressing up like Alice
Cooper and Freddie Mercury
and wishing that I
could be a rock star.
So I really wanted
to be an actor.
And I got to be.
So that was no
longer the fantasy.
The fantasy, to this day,
is still rock and roll.
So I did this show where I sang.
It was myself and my piano
player who is a friend of mine.
He's the keyboard
player for The Who.
So already, there's kind
of a fantasy level there.
He put together this band.
And I sang-- it was mostly songs
by popular artists but not.
The songs themselves
were like B-sides
and, like, you know,
the last song on side
three of some album that--
but they were my favorites
when I was 16.
And I had stories behind them.
And when Elton John
did "Will and Grace,"
there was a story behind that.
So I'd tell that story.
Then I did this rare
Elton John song.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Right.
I feel like doing a
sitcom-- this kind of plays
on her question a little
bit-- doing a sitcom
would be more enjoyable for you
in that it is more theatresque.
Right?
Because you're in front
of a live audience.
You only do a couple takes.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I mean, in a
theatre, you have no retakes.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly.
And as you were
pointing out, twice,
we did actually
live episodes, like,
as America was watching
them, we were doing them.
And those were-- they didn't
look as good because it
was videotaped, but
it was tremendous fun.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Well, do you prefer that?
Do you prefer the live
aspect, versus [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC MCCORMACK: I really do.
I mean, I'll always do back to
the theatre because I do love
that a lot.
And a show like this
takes it out of you
because it's-- anyone that
does an hour drama, I mean,
it's non-stop.
It's just--
ALAN SEALES: Do you
do an episode a week?
Is that a typical schedule?
ERIC MCCORMACK: It's
a seven day schedule.
But, you know, we
have weekends off.
So yeah.
But it's seven days.
ALAN SEALES: So for how long?
You film for three months?
ERIC MCCORMACK: January to June.
We're finished next week.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, wow,
because you're still
filming the finale?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
I go back and shoot tomorrow.
ALAN SEALES: Well, sorry.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Now is
the time when I'm happy.
No, because we premiere
tomorrow night,
and it's so great
to get the word out.
As I was saying before,
it's a smaller universe now,
but you still--
it puts everything
you have into
something like this.
And you just want people to
see it, and you want to--
ALAN SEALES: Well, speaking
of getting the word out,
you have a Twitter account
that you want to plug here?
ERIC MCCORMACK:
It's @EricMcCormack.
And yes, please.
I've got 70,000 loyal followers.
And I want more.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, we
had a question jump up.
Yeah?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm a really big TV fan.
So I watch a lot
of different shows.
And "Will and Grace" is
one of the earlier ones
that I watched when I started,
about six years ago, just
watching all of the
seasons that I could.
And the Emmys have changed a
lot since you and your show
have been nominated
and won and everything.
And I was wondering what you
think about the Emmys today
and how television has kind
of changed since you've
kind of done sitcoms,
versus now, doing a drama.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Well, you know,
Jim Parsons, from, I think
"Big Bang Theory"
is the closest thing
to what we used to do
that is on television now.
And he's brilliant.
And so when I see
that kind of show win,
I go, well, not that
much has changed.
But certainly, in terms of
drama and what cable is doing,
it's changed entirely.
I mean, I think almost
everything nominated
this year was not from
a network, you know?
But I think that's OK.
That old the way has to go.
It benefited those of us
that were on popular shows
because we got a big
number of people.
It was less to choose from.
But those days are gone.
I mean, everyone in this
generation, with Google
and everything else, we can
choose whatever we want.
ALAN SEALES: On your cell phone?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah,
on your cell phone.
So the Emmys are, in
and of themselves,
going to become less
representational of what's
really out there.
I think nowadays, if I
were on a great cable show,
doing great work, and
still not nominated,
I wouldn't take it
all that personally.
I mean, there's just too much
good stuff to choose from.
So I don't know.
That could change.
There's still only ever
going to be five nominees.
And they will not
necessarily represent
what everyone's watching.
AUDIENCE: They
actually recently said
that they might consider doing
a best show, which combines
both the best series categories
together, because there
have been changes.
What would you think about that?
ERIC MCCORMACK: What
do you mean best show?
AUDIENCE: Instead of best
comedy series, best drama,
they would combine it into 10.
How do you think that would--
ERIC MCCORMACK: I
find that weird.
AUDIENCE: It was a weird
little theory that people had,
out there.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah.
I find that strange.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, is this the
Emmy fan of [INAUDIBLE] rumors?
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yeah, because
I think comedy and a drama
are very different animals.
You know?
You know what's very strange?
It was the Golden
Globes or something.
"Will and Grace" has
the record for the most
Golden Globe nominations
with no wins at all.
It's true.
Look it up.
25 nominations, and
none of us ever won.
And every year, we'd
go get the same table.
And Max, who created the show,
every time somebody wouldn't
win, he would grab his
glass, and we'd all go, yeah!
And we'd cheer.
And so the cameras would always
come to us like we'd won.
But we hadn't.
Some other guy was walking
up and taking the thing.
But I think it was at the
Globes that the category
for Supporting Actor
is for everything.
Best Supporting Actor
on any television
show-- drama, miniseries.
So Sean always managed to
get nominated [INAUDIBLE],
but always with this pool
of, like, opposite Vanessa
Redgrave or something.
It was just madness.
So when you start to
make it too small,
the award starts to have
less-- I mean, for me,
it meant so much because the
big show, for me, growing up,
was "Get Smart" which was--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
ERIC MCCORMACK: I didn't
see it's original run,
but I saw reruns in the '70s.
And Don Adams won that award.
You know?
Actually, there's
a famous story--
I don't know if it's apocryphal
that on Emmy night, you know,
the Emmys have the wings
that are really sharp.
And apparently,
he and Don Rickles
got so drunk that Don Adams
fell asleep on his Emmy
and punctured his throat and
was bleeding all over his tux.
I don't know if that's true.
But I love that story.
But just the fact that--
ALAN SEALES: You said it
here, and now it's true.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly.
Now it's back.
ALAN SEALES: Now
it's on the internet.
ERIC MCCORMACK: But the
fact that he won that award,
and then 35 years
later, I won that award.
The fact that I shot "Will
and Grace" on the same lot
that Seinfeld shot on.
And on our stage, Bob
Newhart shot his show.
I love that history.
And the Emmys is part of that.
Thanks for the question.
ALAN SEALES: Great.
So the show premieres
tomorrow, June 17th--
ERIC MCCORMACK: Yes, it does.
ALAN SEALES: On TNT which is
channel 103, here in New York,
at 10:00 PM.
Website is
tntdrama.com/series/perception.
There's a Facebook
page, /perceptionTNT.
There's a Twitter
handle, #perceptionTNT.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Exactly right.
ALAN SEALES: YouTube,
/perceptionTNT.
And there's even GetGlue?
GetGlue.com /tv_show/perception.
ERIC MCCORMACK: That
was my laundry list.
Sorry.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Glue.
GetGlue.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Right.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
And then you're Eric McCormick.
ERIC MCCORMACK: I am.
@EricMcCormack.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
So thank you.
ERIC MCCORMACK: Thank
you, guys, for coming out.
I really appreciate it.
ALAN SEALES: All right.